hi everyone and welcome to nfc 2020
um today we're talking about building a
rock-solid serverless applications
my name is william liebenberg i'm a
solution architect at ssw
you can find me on twitter i've got a
website called azuregems.io so you can
find some cool tips about azure
you can find me on linkedin so if you
want to engage a bit more formally
um and just a bit of my background i
started programming was about five years
old
i wrote my first program on a spectrum
video
three two eight it's a big clunky beige
looking thing like this and
it had whole 8k of memory everything
else after that had to be loaded from
cassette tapes
they hardly ever exist anymore so long
before the internet
and cd-roms and all that kind of stuff
so everything was pretty basic back then
um and then uh you know years later i
started developing
professionally in 2004 but this was
when ide is pretty much low raised
compared to
these days but still we felt like we
could rule the world with source code
eventually i moved over to dot net
version two
skip version one because i thought
what's this crazy new technology it's
not gonna last but hey
happy to say it was wrong we've got net
five these days
uh it's been with us for so so long and
it is fantastic
i spent many years in the 3d
industrial training uh industry virtual
reality and i'm lucky enough to get one
of the very first oculus dev
oculus rift dev kits in australia to
help train people in their jobs to work
safely so they don't hurt anyone else
or themselves then i fell in love with
azure
in about 2014. so about six years ago uh
not a day goes by that i don't use azure
it's definitely it's so big there's
something for everyone
and today we're going to have a look at
a small slice of azure
so we start off by looking at what is
clean code and the solid principles then
how do we apply that to building
and architecting our serverless
applications
then i want to sort of go and see what
can we do to harden our applications
and add some resiliency and make sure
then they can perform
you know scale efficiently and yeah
let's get started with clean code
so why bother with clean code well i'm
sure we've all been
in this scenario the you know we do
aspirate reviews or code reviews
and you know we measure the quality of
code as a standard measure
the wtfs per minute so uh
you know solid principles help us sort
of to either you know make sure we have
this very low
rate of wtfs per minute now one end
you'll have the devs that sort of come
in there the duct tape coders they just
quickly fix it up and say yeah it works
uh you know whatever tech that we've
created we'll take care of it later ship
it right now
on the other end we can have the
architectural asthma astronauts
and they can talk about architecture all
day long
you know and never actually ever write
any code never get anything out the door
and they're very expensive these guys so
um
you know is it worth it so i think for
us
we should go and find a middle ground so
that we can write
you know nice code and simple you don't
spend too much time on it
and they're gonna have good
architectures that are easy to reason
about and you know get our product
out the door and uh you know
have something of value out there so
with clean code
there's two main areas we want our code
easy to be honest to understand
and it should also be easy to change so
looking at the execution flow should be
easy to understand you read the code
it just makes sense everything that the
classes do or the way they interact to
be nice and simple
and you know you don't have to spend a
lot of time trying to figure it out
then when we need to change our code uh
you know things should only have one
reason to change so that single
responsibility is very important
and again just looking at your class
interface should be simple easy to
understand
and it should do really what it says on
the box
you don't want to say create new
customer and
inside it actually goes and deletes a
customer that's just not nice
so all these things put together it's
nice it's very important
and there's sort of been summed up in
five principles that formerly
solid principles and they were
popularized by
uncle bob or rob martin in his book
clean code so if you're not familiar
with these principles
yet that's fine we're going to go
through them um
and but if you are just maybe put your
hand up in the chat there and
let me know what you think about it one
side effect
of writing clinton code is that you
actually end up with
a lot of code and a lot of files
so you need a way to organize this and
this is where clean architecture comes
in
so clear architecture sort of gives you
the ability to write the core of the
application
it's independent of any other frameworks
it's all testable highly testable you
can take the ui
let's say it was originally written with
react you can swap that out and use
blazer
latest and greatest or you can swap from
sql server to
cosmos db no problem see the core of
your application shouldn't need to
change
for any reason it doesn't depend on
anything external so for instance if
you're
you're upgrading a dependency the core
of the application shouldn't need to
change
um and this is all possible because the
dependencies all point inwards
you can see the arrows there nothing's
pointing outwards so any changes that
you're made on outside
don't change the code in the middle
really nice so if you want a template
for getting a clean architecture project
up and running in seconds you can check
out jason taylor's
uh clean architecture solution on github
and just a few more rules about you know
clean architecture and
a lot more coded examples you can check
out the rules of clean architectural
link at ssw
okay so now we know what clean code is
about
what solid principles there are and how
are we now
going to apply that to servers
okay i'm going to take a simple
application
and call this our classic example
uh it's just a simple app there's a
server there's a database
and a static site these days in azure
we'll say it's a static web application
so the icon's slightly out of date
already but
it's very much the same thing all right
and we've got our readers
that go to the site and with authors
that go and add new content
but people like to imagine
uh the world's case scenarios so uh when
things go wrong
and go really wrong your
server ram or hard drive space
yeah things just stopped working we
don't have connectivity to an
application
we can't update our site we can't even
get to the database
you know so we're
starting to panic and you know we don't
really know what our user experience is
going to be right now because
well even the static site can't access
the api for
any sort of dynamic information okay so
we go away and try and figure out what
can we do to make this better
and you'll definitely run into
serverless but why would you want to go
down the serverless path well when a
server goes down
you don't know about it you know the the
serverless providers
azure aws gcp they'll just take care of
that for you
you generally tend to spend less money
with
serverless because the way that it
scales sort of on demand for you
you get rid of that over provisioning
problem
or under provisioning given so by
digging a bit deeper
you know why you want to use serverless
well
they remove or abstract all that
hardware issues away for you
and you just focus on your codes it's a
very simplified programming model
it even helps to simplify your devops
because applications are smaller
they have less dependencies you know
they might just have one database
rather than some applications can have
access to multiple
databases and dependent services so yeah
it supplies their box
like i said it helps you with the
problem of
over or under provisioning your
infrastructure your resources
so you don't have a gigantic server that
is only being utilized in five percent
of it
or you're always running at 100 and you
can never
fulfill all the requests so this
consumption based building you basically
only pay for what you use
uh and no more which is really cool and
event driven scaling so
that's really important because uh our
application can do
um things that look at blob storages you
know react of when a file is uploaded
somewhere or
um someone sends you a message not just
a http message but
from a message bus or signalr for
instance
so whenever those messages come in and
we start getting a spike
our application can quickly scale out
and take care of just running smoothly
for us
now because the applications are smaller
they have less dependencies
and you know they sort of start having
less coupling
so we don't have a gigantic service that
or a monolithic service that needs to
know about five or six or more
dependencies down the track so
everything's just loosely coupled
and it's easier to test and you can just
have much better confidence
once you do release your application
so looking at the serverless services
available in azure
um you know for compute we have azure
functions
uh logic apps we can even run everything
inside of
kubernetes as serverless container
instances
it's pretty cool when it comes to data
there's
cosmos db even solar sql is now a thing
which is really cool
and storage so you know we basically can
just
uh be concerned about data we don't have
to worry about the unlike
hardware at all you just put that record
there
put that file there done and it works
for us
um another set of services i want to
look at is messaging services
so we have actually quite a lot of them
available so
um azure service bus event hub event
grid
uh even signal r service uh it's they're
all available
and they're serverless and they just
scale to whatever demand we need
i'm going to pick these three i'm going
to start with
azure functions because they scale
elastically
you know i want my application to
quickly just spin up
uh more instances when my application
gets used heavily
and when things die down scale back down
to
zero and then i don't pay anything it's
really nice
the benefit is also that we can run
azure function apps
anyway so not just in azure as functions
as a service
while we run them in containers you can
even run them on a prank
so anyone can run there's no more vendor
locking that
people be concerned about
it provides a no simple sort of model
but it's actually
not only sql so there's a few other
varieties that we can use
from customers db like graph databases
column wide databases
with cassandra and even mongodb so
a lot of models are supported really
nice and it can
elastically scale so in my application
can ask cosmos to be hey
quickly scale up we've got a heavy
operation coming in and when you're done
scale back down and it happens very fast
very nice
a really cool feature that we have as
well is change notification
um so what this is once you write a
record or an item
or a document everything's got more than
one name when you write a document to
cosmos db
you can actually trigger some custom
azure function code to run um
you know which is like the side concern
it's not maybe part of your main
application but you still want to react
to that event
maybe you want to pre-cache some data or
generate a separate report
and you don't want to then have to go
and bake that into your main application
this is really nice so you can take care
of some other cross-cutting concerns
using the change feed and finally
with service bus when it comes to
sending messages they guarantee the
delivery of that message
so once it goes into the bus it'll
always be able to
be read at the other end
and we can do that with different things
we can use just plain
cues or we can use topics with
subscriptions and filters and we'll look
at them a little bit later
very very cool
so we take that classic application we
saw earlier
and you know after a bit of playing
around you know these are the resources
we chose and broke the application up
into a few smaller pieces
so we're going to use azure service bus
to
send messages and have
our functions listen to a topic and
whenever a message
arrives it will trigger that function
application to run
and produce some sort of output
and then for our database like i
mentioned earlier you can use the change
feed
it's very handy when a record is written
to the database
we can raise an event or trigger an
event and run some custom code to
take care of something uh that's not
built into the main application or even
that's not part of the
main domain of the application at all
is the single responsibility single
responsibility principle
it means that the only one code have one
reason
change this principle actually goes hand
in hand with one
further down the line the interface
segregation principle
but i'm going to cover them separately
so
an example of uh srp with our
application
is the resize images application
um so if i need to change this
application
uh it's only because i need to do
something about images
it has absolutely no concern about
the markdown that we process in another
application
so you know i don't make a change here
and down the line something else wiggles
around
and you know it is basically just
focusing changes on one small bit of
functionality
one application as it is in our case
um so yeah with a random map down like
mentioned if i change it i don't want
anything to
change in the render images application
at all
the next two principles you can sort of
combine them together
and build something really nice so the
open close principle
it means open for extension but closed
for
modification so imagine
we have just version one of an
application out
and uh you know we want to improve on
that
uh you know we don't wanna go and just
rip out the application from production
and slot the new one in you can do that
in a really nice way
with azure functions um an
lsp or the list off substitution
principle
is that we can take an implementation
and swap it out
for something that it does the same
thing so like i mentioned in our example
this is just a smaller slice of that
application
with the resize images again uh
let's say now i want to go right version
two
it does the resizing quicker it probably
has a bit higher quality
but you know i don't wanna have to you
know swap the
version one in uh swap out version one
straight away while i'm developing
version two so i can actually deploy
version two
straight away i can react to the same
messages that
version one gets i can test that output
can write it to a different site
uh or you know anywhere else just to
have some way of monitoring the output
from that
and once i'm happy cool i hook that up
i'll put its output back to production
i can turn off the messaging for version
one now it's gone
version two is running and yeah it's all
happening very quick
and easy cool
now this is the interface segregation
principle and this one for me is very
important
people tend to try and write massive
great apis
and then we end up with even monolithic
serverless applications
so when you have an application try and
limit the
number of endpoints or the number of
features that you're trying to build
into that application
there's a few basic benefits that you
get so you have less dependencies
potentially so your application binaries
are going to be smaller and that also
helps
to not improve just the cold start times
which is a serverless feature um
but it also helps your applications
scale out quicker
so when when that event driven demand
comes in
and your application has to scale in the
background of course
your application sorry the
azure will have to provision some more
vms copy the code from
a storage account onto the vm spin it
all up and if your application's smaller
starts quicker
you can react quickly
it was just a huge application
four seconds to boot up connect
functionality or again in this case
resizing images it can scale up really
quickly
and scale up quite widely kind of many
instances are running
to do a lot of the work very quickly and
efficiently
so we can only scale out one small bit
of functionality for our application
unlike the classic version where we have
to scale up the entire application
so we don't need huge amounts of
horsepower to turn markdown code into
html for instance
but images for sure they take a lot more
processing power
so this is very ideal very nice
the last principle is the dependency
inversion principle
and as it says code towards the
interface
and for a long time i was trying to
figure out hey
how am i going to take this principle
and apply this to a serverless
architecture
and the keyword here is code so
that's what we do with our applications
not what the applications can do to each
other
so there's no easy way for me to apply
this to an architecture
other than being able to actually now do
it in our service applications
so for a long time our serverless
applications didn't have
a way of doing dependency injection
which is important for clean code
coding towards the interface that we can
then go and
swap out an implementation but now we
can it's really good
and actually helps us write a really
clean application so i'm still going to
take that one as a win
here's an example uh here is one of the
service bus triggers so it receives a
message
from a particular topic on a particular
service
and what they're doing is uh just
sterilizing that message
into one that we can understand and a
lot of times
um
endpoints uh that are really thick
they're very skinny
very simple to understand um and
just like with classic web apis we have
a very thin controller
and a very small action so we've
injected the dependencies via the
constructor for our serverless
application and it's very easy
it all fits on one screen essentially
and then you know that
that request that came in sends it
through mediator and then it gets
handled here as a
uh asynchronous request handler
and we have again dependency injection
through the constructor
and then in the handling method we have
the incoming request object
and we can in this case go and download
the original image
resize it and return the output
cool so looking back
serverless and solid principles we can
pretty much tick
each and every one of these say hey cool
now we have at least
five good principles that we can use to
reason about
how to build or architect our service
applications
uh you know we're not sort of stabbing
in the dark these are things that have
been uh tried and tested over 30 years
or so
some of them have a long long history um
and it makes life easier
it lets us not just write simple code
but
build simple architectures that are easy
to understand and then make sense
everything does exactly what it says on
the box
cool so okay now we know we can write
some cool
solid applications everything easy to
understand
how do we harden our applications
once we send it out into the wild all
sorts of things can happen
um so this is where my applications
and what
that message that goes into the system
if something happens you know
server runs on memory restarts or
whatever uh we don't want to lose that
operation you know that's potential
revenue that we're basically missing out
on
so want to make sure that we don't lose
those operations we want to keep them
even though something goes wrong
in the middle but we want to assume the
operation as soon as possible
once things come back online we just
want to keep going and not
be too concerned and yeah this is
because we do
want to provide a highly available
service
so when do we start panicking well we
always imagine
natural disasters and people joke the
data center is on fire
but that almost never happens anyways
lightning strikes
very it almost just never happens um but
what happens often
is when someone accidentally restarts a
service
uh i'm sure we've all been there uh or
just part of your normal cicd
pipeline or a devops cycle when you
deploy your application
you have to take it offline and you have
to swap in the new version
that just has to happen and in that
window
customers can still access your
application and it may not work
and then just trans and errors you know
these things happen for instance when
um that uh classic application i showed
earlier
uh suddenly i want to convert 50 images
um and my storage just can't handle it
or i need to store a whole lot of
documents in the database
and i'm just running out of connections
though so those sort of transit errors
they do happen
or even just when you make a
configuration change to your
application um often they just have to
restart to be able to have that setting
tape effect
so all of these can actually make you
panic
and we want to be able to deal with that
and not actually losing valuable options
in our application
so just looking at the setup for our
basic application again
when things go wrong we lose all
connectivity
we really start painting we don't know
how the users are experiencing the
application really you know
they may or may not come back at all so
how do we
how do we uh solve this how do we get
rid of
uh the sort of brittleness and have our
applications nice and
resilient well one way that we can
do or achieve that is to use
asynchronous
messaging so this is where the azure
service bus type services
come in it's not the only one but it's
one i've chosen for today
um it's just because http requests
they suck they have timeouts and you
know
uh you can't recover from that timeout
really
once it's that operation is lost
if the user doesn't want to come back to
your website to submit that order or you
click that buy button
well you've missed out it's not going to
happen
the nice thing about messages in these
sort of services
is that they have persisted over outage
periods
so as soon as you've received that
message uh
it's yours and you can um keep it for a
long time
and make sure that you process it at
some point and then at least make sure
that that buy or that cell
operation goes through and you actually
still have a happy
customer and also reduce coupling
between the applications
so when we think about clean code even
um
you know there's the term new is glue so
if we
couple our classes together um they're
very hard to
refactor how to change and how to swap
out behaviors right
so when we use this sort of asynchronous
messaging through a bus
then we don't need to couple services
together we literally say hey
i'm raising an event i'm throwing a
message into the bus saying
order created and any service
that's listening to that bus uh can pick
it up and react to it
we don't know who it is so basically we
can fire and forget the messages
because uh you've done your bit this one
service has done its bit
and it just sort of throws into the bus
and the next
servers can pick it up and continue its
process
so it's really nice but again
even though such a nice service we have
to look at which
patterns to use to make them highly
available we can even actually use some
highly available services
already um so let's say for instance
cosmos db
makes it really simple you can spin up a
cosmos instance
and say i want to run this in
not just in melbourne but around in
sydney new york and la
you know this that's my customer base
and i can literally do that with four
clicks it's nice and simple
and you can turn on a nice feature
that's uh going to make it even better
so it's called multi-master right to
compare what that means with
sql server is of course sql server can
run
across the globe in multiple regions but
you can only write back to the
single master node uh so if i have
a a customer from new york
wanting to write something to the
database they have to come
that request has to go all the way down
to here in melbourne if that's where my
master mode is
that's a long time to need a lot of
latency for that operation to complete
by turning on multi-master rights in
cosmos
that customer in new york can write to
the new york instance straight away
and reads you know whatever uh
information from that database
straight away as well it's highly
available it's uh
and cosmos actually takes care of that
replication all the way back to
australia for us all the masternodes
in each region has the same information
and then yeah so it means if anything
happens to our sydney or melbourne nodes
the ones in america they're all still
functioning fine nothing wrong with
application it's
all good um then for
our applications um there's sort of the
outbox pattern um
instead of directly sending messages
right away when we need to
we can actually sort of have like a um a
persistent store in the application just
to make sure that hey
i know these are the messages i need to
send and i'm going to work my hardest to
send them as quickly as possible so even
if the application did go down
halfway through sending in a message uh
when it starts back up it'll go oh i
didn't finish that
message i can actually resume and send
it out so it's really
um you know valuable pat and it's not
actually very hard to implement
uh in your applications and just retry
patents so these are
in the instances where let's say i'm
trying to
do a select from the database and it
fails
i've run out of connections for some
reason that's like a transient error
so instead of reusing that very same
connection we can retry with new
connection
until we do it like a hard fail um so
these are simple you can use poly it's a
very
popular library that we can use for net
and yeah it's definitely worth
implementing these patterns
to make sure your app is resilient and
before you do hard fails at least you
try your best to recover
so
when we look at our um
our serverless application uh when
things go wrong
and they do because you know nothing's
perfect
even though it's serverless things do go
wrong but
when they you know when do we start
panicking
well as soon as the applications start
coming back
online uh you know they don't all come
back at the same time it might take
a little while for them all to come back
but let's say the first one comes
online that's okay because the messages
are persisted in the bus and they're not
removed from the bus until it's
processed successfully excuse me
so that's that's really really nice and
yeah same with the other functions
uh even for uh cosmos db
when they come back online they go oh
you know there's been a number of
changes since i last
read the the database so you know we'll
just
resume from that checkpoint and keep on
processing we've literally not lost
anything
um again just sort of messages now we've
got documents coming down the wire
and we can process them as soon and as
quick as
possible and yeah that's just nice
because
eventually everything's back online
we've missed no operations
and we can stop panicking nice and
simple
so looking at service bus itself
uh we need to make this highly available
um you know you're spinning up normally
just one instance
but you know it's in one region and it
does something in a region can fail you
always have to have something
available elsewhere in the world where
there's no disaster and you always fail
over to that
hopefully that it's not too far away so
even though it is um just a little bit
distance away it's not too far away so
you don't want to have too much
uh latency in your application
so what we do we take our service bus
instance we deploy it into two or more
regions
and then we look at say an active active
replication pattern
and what that means is our sending
application
it sends the same message to both
service buses
but on the receiver end you know we're
not going to receive the same message
twice so this is where we have to make
sure that
either if we want to process the same
message twice
the second one doesn't have a negative
impact or no
side effects to to that operation uh so
the term which is one of the harder
words in english to say is uh
independent
idempotent however you say it everyone's
got their version
of saying it but yeah so all we have to
then find a way
to de-duplicate the messages at the
receiver's end so we only
process that message once um
now um not everyone i've talked to has
actually been able to achieve this it's
actually quite hard sounds simple
but um it's a fair effort to make this
work you have to
have a store available at each
application that receives a message to
look up correlation ids and all that
sort of stuff but then for how long do
you
keep all that information there's a lot
of complexity involved in this pattern
it works obviously but it's very hard to
do with a better
approach would be the active passive
replication this is actually the
recommended
pattern from microsoft as well uh for
service bus because we don't have to
deal with that
deduplication of our messages um
and it's quite simple we still have two
buses
uh one's an active and one's a passive
bus uh
they're both in different regions so we
first always send
messages to the active bus and only when
that send operation
fails we'll fail over to the passive one
but our receiving application listens to
both as well
just like with active active we're
listening to both active
and passive busts at the same time
so what that looks like looks like this
we have our sending application
uh on the one end and it sends the same
message
to both of the buses our listening
application receives it
but then we have to go through and uh
you know
deduplicate that message before we can
actually handle it or process it
through our application that looks
simple but that one step is sometimes
very hard to implement properly the
active passive
replication uh looks like this so
you start with the the sender
application
sends message one it goes through the
bus uh the
listening application uh can receive it
process it not a problem
message two fails the same through the
active bus
and you know so we can actually retry
that if we wanted to
try the retry patterns uh but uh
when that fails we then send through
that the very same message message
number two
to the passive bus and the listener can
pick that up and just process it
so you'll receive only one message from
either of the
service buses you're not going to
receive the same message twice
so nice and simple and this works really
really well
but then how do we make our azure
functions highly available
well again we start by deploying them
into multiple
uh regions there are multiple instances
of that application are now running in
azure
um but going the other way if you look
at the active passive pattern from
before
um each application will have to know
that there is
two receiving applications in two
regions so we actually have to
build a lot of logic into our
applications when you want to send
a request between the services and you
know
try and file over manually which is
quite
a bit of annoying work that we need to
do so
if you look at the active active pattern
which actually is the recommended
pattern for serverless applications
or at least something that goes over
https
but you think the problem is with active
active is that
i'm going to receive the same request
twice
more than once uh and that makes me sad
because
as we saw we have to de-duplicate and
make sure that if we run the same
operation
the second time there's no weird side
effect but
there's actually very cool service that
we can use to solve this problem for us
uh
azure front door um and what that looks
like is once we spin up azure front door
we get a new uh public endpoint for
our application and we register all our
apis for different regions
in front door we can even set up some
awesome routing policies if we need to
um and front door will actually do like
a near instant failover between the
regions
for any request that comes in and in
fact it will actually
find that the closest or fastest region
to route to for any request that comes
in um
so you can see here we've got two sets
of apis in australia southeast
and australia east and front door just
takes care of sending the
request through the right one now
traditionally if we did use sql
server as a database
we'd actually have to set up a sql
server in both regions
and then set up replication between
those regions
but with cosmos db we don't have to
worry about that because we can just
tick a couple of features
and they take care of it for us so this
little the scenario actually builds
really simple
nice and easy and you don't really need
a
dba or a database engineer that can set
up that replication
for us but now
if we go and we take
the uh the two patterns that we looked
at
for high availability and we combine
them into the whole setup here
so we have our front door running our
applications across
regions and we have a highly available
service bus
set up here and we want to follow that
active passive pattern for service bus
this is what it looks like yeah at first
it might be like oh what's all the
arrows and
a bit of mind-boggling but it actually
works really nicely
um so for each region it will have its
primary
and passive a
primary secretary or active passive bus
and they will actually just ping pong or
switch
depending on which region it is and uh
it actually you know at first i thought
hey this is going to be hard to build it
might not work
built it and it works really nicely and
it's a far easier than i thought
so definitely give this a try so
just looking at you know service bus
messaging you're sending
messages just a couple tips is to
in your base message that you send is to
include all in basic information as you
can
so what message type it is you know uh
correlation ids are important so you can
track that across
multiple services and or multiple um
operations
um and even you know where it came from
and whatever
anything that is is valuable so have
that available in your base message
so anyway everyone can sort of have a
common way to
handle this message so in the azure
functions
we use the service bus trigger to listen
for incoming
messages on a particular topic or queue
even if you want to use that um
and to send messages we can use the
topic client now you can also use a um
the service bus output binding but if
i'm using the topic client deeper inside
of the application usually a bit more
convenient
if you want some code i have a fairly
big project there that you can look at
for
a sort of modern enterprise service bus
workshop that we did
a few months ago for ndc melbourne
brendan richards and i did this
you can have there just grab all the
code it's all all there it does pretty
much everything that
we talked about up until now but just
to give you a bit of a taste of what's
in there here is a way of
sending messages now to fit this on one
screen it's not
the version where it does the failover
to the passive one
but you know it will be pretty easy to
implement so we start off by
making sure that any base message that
comes into
our message sender we encode that to
youtube aid
we serialize it as json and we make sure
to
include the the data type um
as the label for that message so uh
at the receiving end we can actually
deserialize that into a concrete
object um so yeah here's just
the message reader that we would have on
the receiving application
this is how we then dig into that
json payload that comes back and we find
the message type and return then
the net type which we can then use for
some jsmd serialization
get the concrete object and
just like earlier here's a service bus
trigger for a request
that comes in we read that message and
if it's a
in our case my base messages
i always um have them as mediator
requests
so i can actually use mediator to then
send that through the pipeline and
eventually in the application handle
that message
and you know here we go so here's a
message that comes in gets handled
and uh we have the original request
and you know just take care of it in
mediator so
very nice and simple
so cool now we know you know clean code
and solid principles
they do apply uh to serverless and we
know
at least you know how to make our
applications resilient with asynchronous
messaging
and high availability patents but what
about
scalability well
okay first i say is make sure that you
know how big you want to scale your
application
uh in azure you've got different ways of
running
your serverless application uh your
azure function application so you can
run it as a consumption
plan which limits you to 200 instances
which is quite a lot the premium plan
even though you've got
more powerful cpus you know multiple
cores
all that uh you're limited to 100
instances um
and if that's not enough then you have
to think about having
multiple plans or you know maybe
even using the consumption plan as an
alternative
definitely when you're looking at the
dedicated app service plans you can run
an azure functions
application on an app service plan
but you're limited severely into the
number of instances that you can
scout out to uh but then if you're
running kubernetes well then it totally
depends
on a lot of things how much hardware
have you got available
and whether or not you want to use the
virtual cubelets
to you know run all those uh um
serverless containers you know
to orchetta you know keita uh to
sort of scale out automatically for you
and scale back down to zero so
kubernetes
it really depends on what you have um
okay then uh like i said earlier it's
very important keep your applications
small you can definitely notice it in
the startup times and the scaling types
when they have a lot of binaries to load
a lot of things to connect on startup
then
it's not great then also
um when your requests come into your
application
try and make the as quick as possible
you know don't try and block on an
incoming request for a long time
um you know as soon as you can return a
message back to the user
you should um and a good tip just for
running your
uh azure function applications is that
um
it needs a storage account to for all
the bindings and triggers to store
information
and you know even invocation logs all
that uh you know to maintain the
application state
um so if your app your
you need to write some uh results to
storage you know if it's images or files
pdfs
anything use a separate storage account
you don't want to
negatively impact the storage that your
application
as a function is using or the runtime is
using to
make the application tick over so
storage is cheap so
why not you can definitely have two
storage accounts for one application
you get a little extra oomph out of your
your application
azure durable functions are awesome uh
in particular i'm just going to call out
the fan out found in pattern
so if you have a request that comes in
and
it's of the sort that you can actually
split it up into
multiple workloads you can use an
orchestrator
and fan out all those operations to
individual
azure function uh activities uh
that's awesome because you can very
easily just scale out to a couple of
hundred instances
and uh let let it all run for you and
it'll then collect or fan
in those results for you
or another name for this pattern this
was a map reduce
pattern so it's nice and simple to give
that a go
then very importantly with
your messages that come your http
request that comes into your application
um turn them into service bus messages
as soon as you can
right so like i said earlier don't try
and block for too long
this if this means though your
application you sort of have to
design for eventual consistency
um because you know if you're not going
to be blocking a request
on a request and waiting for the result
to come back and send that back to the
caller
instead you send back like a 202
accepted
message and give them a way to query for
the result
uh that will be processed and made
available uh eventually so um
you can use something like signal life
service for instance to
then uh do push notification back to the
recording after say hey
that job you requested it's ready here's
the result
um so and then when you use service bus
try and use topics because if you use
cues
a cue lets you is limited to just one
consumer one listener if you use topics
then you can actually each topic gets a
separate queue
and you have filters on them uh then
that lets people subscribe to so you can
actually have multiple listeners
to one queue it's really awesome and
that lets you run a whole lot of stuff
in in parallel so you can trigger
multiple applications running off
that one topic uh and this one
also i'm very surprised at this so
following the sort of best practices
you with your access policies in service
bus
you want to give the application the
minimum capability possible
to you know reduce any sort of surface
area for things going wrong
uh you know if an application is only
going to ever be listening from
a service bus it only needs to listen
right or if it's only a sender
it needs a sending right uh the manager
right to sort of
give that just to a an admin type
application but the problem is
with the uh the serverless the service
bus trigger
if it doesn't have the manage capability
or manage rights sorry
it can't peek into the service bus queue
to see how long the queue is
and then it can't proactively scale out
for you i tried this on an app
recently it's like oh it actually just
scales a lot quicker
i get more instances spun up and it just
gets the job done
a lot faster so it's much more efficient
uh surprising
uh some of the the security conscious
people might say don't do that
but i'm sure you can convince them with
the end performance results are much
much nicer so here's what the topic
would look like in service bus uh you
can have multiple filters you can
actually
say hey the messages that come into this
topic i only want to filter on some of
them
you know you can actually do write like
sql filters to say uh only
um you know messages of a particular
data type or
from a particular person or service
i want to have and then you make that
available as a subscription so you can
have
one or more apps subscribe to that and
trigger on it when the message does
arrive
and also now because we scale out really
widely and
produce a huge amount of results when
you want to store your data it makes
absolute sense to make sure that you
choose the right storage
uh service so you know to match that
high throughput
so cosmos db is awesome you can
provision a huge amount of throughput it
does cost a bit of money
but the cool thing is you've got auto
scaling as well so
it makes that job nice and easy so no
point trying to store huge amounts of
results
into something that's really slow you're
actually just going to slow down your
application
and hurt your scalability quite a lot so
you've got a few options
your cosmos db event hub premium storage
and even sql server itself
obviously has huge performance
capabilities so
yeah just choose the right one for your
application
and this will go sort of best practice
when
you deal with connections to services
try and reuse the connection clients
uh don't manually try and spin up a
connection
for each azure functions application
because very soon your
cosmos or sql server for instance
they'll run out of connections
um and you know you're gonna have a lot
more transient errors
and it'll just slow you down so yeah go
for
the the clients that use connection
pooling
and manages that whole thing for you
all right so wrapping it up in summary
uh go and use serverless over the
traditional approach
it definitely makes your applications
very easy to understand they're easy to
maintain and
extend they're definitely testable you
know smaller bits of
functionality is very easy to test so
you can have a lot of confidence once
you ship your application
and definitely solid it gives you a way
to reason about your service
architectures yeah you can keep things
very
clean very simple and everyone can come
in and
understand it asynchronous messaging
over http
uh requests it definitely has a lot of
benefit so you can
have better resiliency uh your
scalability uh
increases and and your coupling between
your services
actually decreases so it has an awesome
devops
um benefit there so it's very easy to
just deploy the smaller bits of
functionality and that whole
coordination around devops
is a lot a lot simpler and
high availability for serverless is
actually quite easy uh
surprisingly i thought oh no it's gonna
be a lot of work but it's super simple
so everyone should be able to give that
a go and finally now you can go
and build some awesome rock solid
service servers applications
and from azure if you want to learn
azure for free uh they make that nice
and easy there's a link
azure.com free if you want to learn more
about azure
uh microsoft learn's got a massive
massive amount of
uh tutorials and things for you to go
through and help you with uh
training for your azure search as well
so it's very useful uh if you join the
newsletter
then you can go to that azure developer
swag link and if you're very quick
you can use that code to grab some free
swag
only the four people from this talk will
get a
pack so if you click on the fingers go
for it
thank you very much
oh cool uh definitely open for questions
everybody got some questions
oh audio coming through
uh if there's no questions thank you
very much everybody for turning up
i hope you really enjoy the rest of nbc
it's been fun so far even though it's
online
it's actually really really really fun
thanks tien what do